urban proximity enables social
interactions some good and some bad when
those interactions are voluntary like
sharing a meal or getting a manicure
then the odds are that everyone expects
to benefit otherwise they'd stay home
but some involuntary interactions like a
mugging or a murder
can do great harm to the whole web of
urban life cities enable crime by making
it easier for thieves or bullies to have
physical access to their victims cities
can make it harder to catch criminals by
increasing the number of suspects in a
classic British murder mystery set in
perhaps a country estate
the clever detective need only sort out
the motives and whereabouts of a handful
of potential perpetrators if Hercule
Poirot at trying to solve a mystery in a
teeming London slum then the number of
suspect will be vast and finding the
culprit might exceed the limits of even
his numerous little gray cells for
millennia cities have paid for law
enforcement professionals to keep city
streets safe indeed the connection
between police and cities is so deep
that the very word police has its roots
in the Greek word polis which means city
law itself is not a particularly urban
thing the English common law evolved for
centuries focusing on the problems of
protecting property rights for rural
land but paying for professional police
only makes sense when they are
protecting enough people police are
essentially a fixed cost that needs to
be shared and sharing that cost requires
sufficient scale preventive patrolling
only makes sense when enough people are
being protected to justify the costs of
the patrolman's time ancient Athens had
something of a police force 300 City and
slaves specialized archers kept order
this was a pretty small number relative
to Athens population which may have
exceeded 300,000 by 430 BC but the
Citians were used more to prevent riots
than to prosecute criminals for normal
crimes Athenians had to press their own
cases in front of 200 or more jurors
Augustus brought order to Roman chaos
with two distinct forms of police three
years after a fire damaged his own home
the princeps created a force of about
7,000 freed slaves in six ad to watch
over the Roman Knight they carried
buckets to fight fires but they also
started fighting crime as well
Augustus also relied on the Cortes
Urbana and his Praetorian Guard
who
more military force to stop riots and
serious public disorders when Rome fell
Europe returned to agrarian ways and
organized public policing largely
disappeared there were fraternal
organizations like the holy
Brotherhood's in Spain or the vemma
courts in Germany that came together to
serve as vigilantes towns might also
have night watchmen
armed primarily with a rattle to raise
the human cry in the event of a
disturbance The Watchmen might serve
under a constable but he was a local
official not a patrolling policeman
wealthy private individuals such as
merchants or powerful clerics might also
hire their own armed guards France is
typically credited with being the
birthplace of modern policing King
Francis the first instituted a roving
military police meant chiefly to check
the plundering of his own soldiers king
louis xiv centralized the french police
force in 1666 and his police would be
particularly focused on paris by the
18th century paris would have over 1,000
policemen and one police chief boasted
to Louis the 15th that whenever three
people speak to one another on the
street one of these will be mine
suggesting the repressive political role
that police would also play during the
Bourbon monarchy the English feared that
oppressive power and so it wasn't until
1829 that Parliament passed the
Metropolitan Police Act to provide a
modern police force for London English
police have been known as both bobbies
and peelers after Sir Robert Peel who
introduced the Act
fears of police abuse have long kept
English police lightly armed carrying
only clubs rather than the revolvers and
automatic weapons that became the norm
both on the continent and in the more
dangerous United States America followed
the English lead in 1838 Boston
instituted its police force which was
organized into the Boston Police
Department in 1854 New York City
organized its own Police Department in
1845 just as in many developing world
cities today America's 19th century
police forces were consistently accused
of corruption laws refloated and
payments would be made to police
officers to turn a blind eye some of the
payments to individual policemen would
work their way up the system and end up
in reaching the coffers of political
machines such as Tammany Hall reformers
would consistently try to fix the system
and some reforms did actually occur
especially when state legislators were
politically opposed to locally
in 1857 New York's overwhelmingly
Republican state legislature decided to
disband New York City's corrupt
municipal police force that served its
Democratic mayor Fernanda wood and to
replace it with a Metropolitan Police
Force that would be led by a former Whig
congressman would initially refused to
disband his municipal police even after
the state Supreme Court ruled against
him the Metropolitan Police then
attempted to take over City Hall but the
Municipal fought back and what became
known as the great police riot the
Metropolitan's were defeated and they
retreated to the office of the city
recorder to tend their wounds eventually
the 7th regiment stepped in and would
surrendered temporarily but the rivalry
between the two forces continued and New
York suffered a crime spree culminating
in the deadly gang war known as the dead
rabbits riot after another adverse Court
ruling would eventually disbanded his
municipal police force but the
corruption of New York City's police
department continued during the 19th
century heyday of Tammany Hall in 1894
Republican state legislators again
turned their gaze upon the
democratically controlled police force
and an inquiry the Lex out committee
exposed the enormous irregularities
alexander williams known as clubber
because of his strong arm tactics was a
particular target of the investigation
when Williams was appointed to the
city's West 13th Street Station in 1876
he relished the opportunities for
extracting bribes from the abundant
saloons and brothels nearby he famously
said I've been having chuck steak ever
since I've been on the force and now I'm
going to have a bit of tenderloin
henceforth the neighborhood will be
known as the Tenderloin district when
the Lexile Commission wondered at how
Williams could afford his cost cop
estate and his Yacht Club or explained
that he had earned his great wealth by
speculating in Tokio real estate the
lexo committee's revelations led to the
election of a reforming mayor William
strong who appointed the young Teddy
Roosevelt to be a police commissioner
Roosevelt started appointing officers
based on merit not political patronage
and he prowled the streets at night to
see if this policemen were awake and
doing their jobs
he's a sigil sin forcement of the city's
anti-alcohol blue laws actually help
strong lose his reelection bid there
were just some laws that New Yorkers
didn't want to have enforced the
Progressive Era enacted numerous police
reforms officers were increasingly
appointed based on exams
professionalization and police rotation
tried to
the ties between policemen and local
businesses that enabled corruption by
the 1960s citizens became increasingly
intolerant to police brutality and
America's cops were criticized for doing
too much and too little as crime rates
surged during the 1970s many observers
thought that social policy is not police
with a solution but crime couldn't be
stopped with public largesse alone and
so under Rudy Giuliani New York again
embraced a strong police force the cops
began to target high crime areas and
followed a strategy known as broken
windows policing that targeted small
quality of life crimes the city did
become much safer and New York now as a
police force that is both effective and
generally quite honest the pleasures of
the city can now be enjoyed without fear
both day and night
the downside of that success is that too
many have been locked up thousands were
imprisoned for minor offenses an
ordinary New Yorkers chafed under
strong-arm tactics like stop and frisk
the task of making city streets safe is
only half-finished
crimes a fraction of what it was but we
have not yet figured out how to fight
crime without imprisoning thousands of
young men
you